[Музика]
привіт, я Анна, і я
сьогодні ваша вчителька англійської мови, просто свідок того, який
піонер на Java Chatel і Mr.
Holly
[Music]
сьогодні ми продовжуємо подорожувати
світом, ми потрапляємо до
англомовних країн, а сьогодні
ми у Великобританії, ми збираємося у великі
міста цієї країни, особливо в те
, яке є головним у Лондоні,
просто  економіст Варма виробництво
прибутку і хамона маккрейн фільм
жахливий крихітний Доха Левайн о привіт містер.  de
crimen yah ведучий о, це блондинка О Ні,
і ми також збираємося поговорити про деякі
граматики минулого простого зустріти Акаша Полаварама
О, програмно, о, мій щойно поклонившись
, це те, на чому ми
сьогодні зупинимося,
тому перш ніж почати, ми збираємося  щоб зробити
деякі зміни з попереднього уроку,
але в пресі mcmooch namo про
витривалість Хохокам 8 лідерство Торіна
що це Яма фактично Маноло Рокко, тому
ми збираємося переглянути порівняння,
які можна зробити з як і не так
чи ні як  давайте перейдемо до вправи,
яка допоможе нам переглянути те, що ми дізналися
минулого разу.
О, Джокер, рекордна сума прибутку, так,
скоротити рекламний підсилювач таратата Шьяма
практично Маноло Харрісон, щоб
порівняння ми мали використовувати як як, так
або ні, як у реченнях нижче  якщо
можливо, ми збираємося використовувати не так, як
у реченнях з лежачим
дном проклятого або не так, як вершину візуального
бюджету наппа, як виживає середній
старший огіа режим практики
заціпеніння  Минулого року погода цього літа була
погана, тому ми порівнюємо дві
однакові речі тут
кілька навіть mo v pd v не видно поблизу
праворуч девіз компанії, так що
чувак з йоги Хіроко Маноло Хіроко Лата показує в’язкість в
горошок, о, Літа, неприємна –
ще піранья  в Маноло
Еліта мій дно над Карраско в
структурі як Доллі Мустафа мо фрик
магніт шок поганий начос ім'я
петровна смін ятха туя формальний пан.
Yamamoto Maserati
- Slovo s, тож давайте подивимось, як це
виглядає в повному реченні,
погода цього літа така ж погана, як і минулого
року,
давайте перейдемо до номеру два, це неважко,
я думав, що це буде насправді
круто шотландська мама або сказав кожен  nana steel
kavacha не винний yo Chico vaviiova зараз
Будда тому ми повинні використовувати not so або not
as тоді ставимо прикметник важкий ми
не вносимо жодних змін до нього після
світу після прикметника ми використовуємо s тому
давайте подивимося, як усе речення  Схоже,
коли ми це виправимо, він не такий важкий, як
я думав, це буде насправді
зрозуміло, і все одно Кібош все одно
вб'є тебе
О Чіко, номер три, ці нові
черевики не зручні мої старі
О Джемма, моя мама Кулатта повинна побачити базуку
Нана все ще  cos richness yok mu Yi star
ah
так як ми можемо сказати, що знову ж таки, якщо у нас
є негативна частка не є два
способи порівняння, ми можемо сказати ні
так, або ми можемо сказати не так, оскільки після цього ми
використовуємо прикметник зручний і ставимо
слово, оскільки ці нові черевики не такі
зручні, як мої старі, давайте перейдемо до
номеру чотири нервував не високий
Монблан,
тому ми повинні порівняти тут дві гори,
які зустрічалися з Болівією Мадхаві Хореб, і
нервує Да Мон, хоче Нанак стати свідком
шоу художника, коли  а Весніна ще покриває
просочена ахора ламан кров реакція
припинилася б robomen нервував до
Капернаума проклятого або деструктора о не як
приблизно не так як так давайте подивимося ми повинні
сказати, що нервував
не так високо, як блондинка Monde ми також можемо
сказати, що  Бенарес не такий високий, як
Монблан О, яміка, впевнена, Мішель, але
ім'я Нана все ще покриває дуб ахора llaman
blonde і останнє речення тут
Лондон цікавий Берлін ми повинні
сказати, що Лондон і Берлін рівні,
коли ми говоримо, що вони цікаві або
Джакомо  Казимир шоу Лондон в Берліні
так,
він навіть бачив, як нацистський уряд Маямі
прирівнює Міатаса в структурі Помона CA
yagamoth каже, що Обама білий
епендимомас, наташка, ми скажемо, що
Ло  ndon такий же цікавий, як Берлін чи
єврей Лондон Nestle Kirstie cava mr.  yuk
in Berlin – це speciai mondo london, о
, тепер давайте перейдемо до нашого рейсу до Лондона
і фактично до Великобританії, перш ніж ми потрапимо до
Лондона, ми відвідаємо деякі найбільші міста Великобританії,
щоб ви могли побачити на
фотографіях три найбільші міста
Великобританії  Tinga Boomers the
Povich підготовленість Міста Бріттані Ой людина
каже: піхви в одному Лондоні,
другий праворуч, це Манчестер, на
малюнку ви можете побачити стадіон Манчестер,
це
стійка футбольна команда Манчестер Сіті, а третє
зображення показує нам Бірму, а зараз це
друге за величиною місто Великобританії, а тепер
давайте поїдемо до Лондона, як було обіцяно, тож
коли ви потрапите в Лондон, коли ви поїдете до
Лондона, ви побачите багато різних
місць у міській
піраміді jukkalan лондонський номер
знизу doja Багамські острови nashnamie Tsutomu
medium oh  Просто скажіть, коли ви рухаєтеся з
ними, гарне відео Vaati Британський
музей, так що висота все одно ми пообіцяли
гомосам Britannica це дивно, Nevada Mr.
Помм'є поговори з Вандою, ні, тому перед тим, як ми
розпочнемо нашу екскурсію, давайте подивимося
на найцікавіші факти про
Британський музей Британський музей
старший за США Британський музей
був заснований у лосося
10:59 гра алгебра плитки була улюбленою
критикою Сатья сказав  Divya to Marat
побачити привабливі сигнали touhou, yeah,
підривають революцію та найбільший
розмовний екстаз Америки О, Джонас, я
не далекобійник Британська хімія, зірка,
вона Америка, тому наступний факт:
музей мав власну станцію метро понад
30 років  років
що таке трубка заткни трубку військо,
загальне найблагороднішого предка вгору.
Насправді трубка — це назва метро
в Лондоні ядерні бомби та метро NASPA Лондон
О JA Британці їдуть додому Хосе Опра 200
покращений дають плазму Штейн же метро,
у наступний інтерес у  Факт про
Британський музей полягає в тому, що це була одна з
перших будівель, де використовувалося електричне освітлення
бретони chemos a sdness natasha
bedeviled sweetie
via key service electric 'no of svitlana
до цього вони використовували сонячне світло для
фактичного освітлення музею, але щоб Вікас
Баль Кілкіс на ногах став
креативним у маленьких шампунях з мозаїкою Liberty,
вони, звісно, не використовували вогонь, щоб за
алити його, тому що було ба
ато книг, і це було досить не
езпечно  для всього музею давайте перейдемо до
останнього факту paraquad скромний на yahoo факт
О Моцарт відвідав музей у
1760-х роках
О Джефф Моцарт з відео вамос a з
дослідженнями його такий шановний естетичний
рак, тому, як ви знаєте, Моцарт був дуже
відомим композитором, тому він пішов  до
Британського музею як одного з сайтів
у Великобританії, і тепер ми потренуємось у
словниковому запасі, перш ніж почнемо
читати текст, або просто смітник із чимось,
що впливає на папугу, але не
сприяє дослідженню Calexico, тож давайте
подивимося  на наступному рейсі слухати читати
повторити і запам'ятати слова я
збираюся читати слова вголос ти можеш повторювати
за мною, ти також можеш побачити
переклад слів на дошці, щоб
це було легко  r, щоб ви їх зрозуміли
Oh je Cazares bodhichitta slava vamos
top of toriaezu MA - MA - MA Anna - siap
Ерік давайте залишимо місяць Заппа Матата
Будда максимум не пощастило давайте
почнемо перше слово - присвятити
натиснути кнопку Веккіо, друге -
встановити встановити кнопку снігу
третє слово є постійним
постійно над Постіні наступне
все ж таки принесено
цей дивний стук наступне слово має
походити від виникло від позитивної
уваги наступне слово зберегти
зберегти дуже гаряча
людина людина Лутц Крі та  останнє слово
тут артефакти артефакти артефакт
поетичний, тому зараз ми читаємо
текст про Британський музей, ми
збираємося дізнатися деякі цікаві факти
про нього, а також ви побачите слова
з цього слайда, підкреслені оджама Арас
Будда Моше Тата текст  Про британських
ескімосів термін ефективний заперечується
bahati sekonic нападники
Повіч Слава співведучі слайд о, хто надіслав смс трохи
грубий liniment  Тож перейдемо до
читання. Британський музей присвячений
мистецтву та культурі людської історії та розташований
у лондонському районі Блумсбері, його
постійна колекція налічує близько
восьми мільйонів творів з усіх
континентів, які ілюструють та
документують історію людської культури від її
початку до  тепер Британський
музей був заснований в 1753 році сьогодні
музей більше не містить колекцій
книг з природознавства та рукописів,
музей, тим не менш, зберігає свої
колекції артефактів, що
представляють культури світу стародавніх
і сучасних, тому ми прочитали текст
про Британський музей, який він розповідає  нам
про те, коли він був створений і що
цікавого ми можемо знайти в
музеї зараз давайте перевіримо ваше
розуміння наше завдання полягає в тому, щоб заповнити
пропуски були слова з поля ви можете
побачити слова і давайте подивимося на
них, перш ніж почати  Виконуючи
вправу, ми маємо такі слова, як
рукописи мистецтво колекція культура
стародавні фр  om your time opera called six
lips Papa right new problem in the white
of the wallet problem and when you post a
little traveling cred Shinya so
recenzent number one British
Museum присвячений чомусь та чомусь
Oh Joe Breton schemas a pares of the white of the walls problem
one ritm yeah Kirsten hm
давайте подивимося, це може бути визначено
лише для рукописів, право win
the motion Будда професійна англійська
рукопис віддалено навіть Будда
професійно мистецтво Mr.  камінь так, я
думаю, нам знадобиться це слово для однієї
з прогалин, колекція лише одна колекція
ні, у культурі Британського музею багато колекцій, чи
можемо ми використовувати це
слово так, безперечно, ми можемо, тому ми
скажемо, що Британський музей
присвячений мистецтву та  культура, тому речення номер
два, його пробіл налічує вісім мільйонів робіт,
ми пам'ятаємо, що в Британському музеї
зберігається багато різних артефактів, що відображають
машину часу. Британія прийшла Узо адуба
Хітачі Кальвін окта артефакт ти
Алаказам — це любов, розробник MPD Данхем щодо
Ко давайте думати після слова
у нас є розрив твердості ви пропонуєте Mr.
Словер розлючений у власній школі Сохо,
тепер дивіться на повільніші цифри.
Донна може розлучитися з маніакальною
Мунною, Джінні, скаже, Джіа схил, лікар,
природно, візум ставка мільйона євро, нам
безперечно потрібен іменник перед цим дієсловом
чи Джен з ампутацією, але стрічка
та лава 90-х років тако  снаряди противника
щодо MU Siobhan із гімнастики,
любовний
вірш Nam no kid no Jetta yep is in my
neck but it's MGS LaVon what could be
the noun here so that what can number 8
million work we will use a very загальне
слово для цього, і це слово  колекція,
тож тут треба сказати, що її
колекція налічує вісім мільйонів творів,
давайте перейдемо до речення номер три,
сьогодні в музеї більше не зберігаються
книги, і, як ви пам’ятаєте з
тексту, було зазначено, що
були спеціальні папери з давньою
інформацією та старовинними  письма,
яких більше немає в Британському
музеї,
ну, це мапування автономних
записок Джо Британіка, створених у Майя
, традиційно протилежне  це
багатство через маленький вакуум ви говорите
слово для цього були б рукописи, тому
ми скажемо, що сьогодні в музеї більше немає
книг і рукописів, тепер ви
можете побачити речення на слайді, і
давайте подивимося на останнє речення
тут  музей щось представляє смерть,
і сучасні культури
світу показали б, що теперішній час був
номером Chevy, тому що VIN-номер, тому що
парафія знала, наприклад, нова, тепер прем'єр-
культура, київська мила в кабінеті Акаша,
ви можете побачити табличку на слайді,
це щось  дуже старий, а синонімом
для дуже старого було б слово стародавній,
тому це те, що нам потрібно для цього
пробілу, музей представляє стародавні
та сучасні культури світу, тому
відвідайте його з текстом, а тепер давайте перейдемо
до граматики минулого простого  це
те, про що ми зараз дізнаємося,
тому ми використовуємо його, щоб
говорити про завершені минулі дії моно
Костова режим pass tempo d'ottavio
ідея збереження даних o Manolo mo
Missouri  Розалінд Амана попередній код як
mophir mo mo минулий зразок
живий біля слалому, щоб бути, тож давайте
подивимося на першу частину слайда,
давайте подивимося у верхній лівий кут,
щоб мати літеру S, яка насправді
означає тему Ігнасіо Літора  як
пігмент предмет oj p slap it meta mobile
DiMaggio Vata для аміаку Слава
бути Jordan a above where glam Majnu
no prequel вони були друзями Yama Yama
Yama is love to be super edgy
mumumu опублікований odorata Beasley ні заручники
не можуть перемогти Oh захист Равана
було не вище ордера звичайний
малайзійський флот проклав на Zola Shia, тому
вони не були друзями, коли
в проповіді, а в
запитаннях, які ми зазвичай потребуємо, використовуємо дієслово
на початку речення, де
вони друзі племінних  навіть трюїзм
новий пост вибачення лава
де не сказав Маніла для моїх дорогих
лава бути невротичним начо має
батальйон ахора-молодший.  тепер давайте
подивимося, як ми утворюємо простий минулий час
з дієсловами that is the vitae but the
home was not a Yakima for my mama no
leeches that was vagina wedgie Islamic
we use subject and the verd in the form and the verd in the form
of ed mo bokura uporn  with
piedmont a piston yo estaba mo GS lava it latosha
pasta body людське знання has my mama
da da ta the Kanchana Edie
наприклад вона працювала вчора
заперечна форма ми використовуємо підмет then у нас
є допоміжне дієслово didn't або did
після якого ми використовуємо  дієслово в
інфінітивній формі OG Latoya магазини перезавантажено
Zappa Regina
Kalina дивись ідеї love Regina mamama
pasta with the Commission idea Слава
не Перес мг/л Славен пегматит
Шираз відомий ng словацька їжа всі
кажуть О мені інфінітив вершина поет піти
раніше  мені
нова Yakuza qingcheng зупинитись у племені напа
зараз наприклад вона вчора не працювала
а тепер питання до
питання ми поставимо допоміжне дієслово
мертвий на початок речення
Наташа бідність Па  tania моя мама
перейшла на ідею дозволу Слава
зараз зловив самодержавство Нія чи вона працювала
вчора це марнославство Августи немає роботи рівня 90-х
Акаш сріваца оо
нескінченний телевізор навпроти кави для мене
в Maya Jordan точний двигун є
також дієслова що  називаються
неправильними неправильні дієслова мають
свою власну структуру вони зазвичай не
мають закінчення edy OJ але
походження Acushnet лава жертвувати при зануренні
не є kimchi needy так
особливий не є відбілювач містять проблему
Nagi спить ви можете допомогти йому не про
встає  a Mia Tata,
тепер давайте подивимося на
використання минулого зразка, який найбільше є vitae, бідний
диявол, і тепер стручок дає вам
Vanya manova is vagina дивитися так собі
на таблиці ви можете побачити використання двох стовпців
та приклад Oh Jimoh  mohammed v :
cap vicar s Tanya apricot давайте
подивимося на перше правило, коли ми можемо
використовувати минуле просте запис на
притчі Амана про Ікара Таня Маноло ха-ча,
щоб виразити завершену дію  ion у
минулому магазин іграшок Rose Quezada збереження
geo woman hola mo not require
Я бачив привиду минулої п'ятниці так, але я
повинен надати Manolo ap вночі, вона
сказала, що роки версія TouchWiz no oj
забрала мою піч у мензурку я в минулому просто
давайте перейдемо до другого правила pareja de
modo Gnostic mahaprabhu, щоб описати
серію виконаних дій у минулому,
наприклад, я закінчив роботу, пішов
до пляжу і знайшов гарне місце для купання.
тиск задоволення десяток шок
для Dava mr.  Latura show pop Levitan
давайте також емоційно Карузо відокремив
минуле просте та останнє
використання останнього правила для вираження звичок
у минулому Latasha bhagavata proza, яку
Kym Illman allama не просив, коли я був
молодим Я дивився багато телевізора
щодня після школи
Коля обидва Malucci  так, Webster Baja
повністю v0p / :
отже, це past simple, ось коли
і як ми його
використовуємо // radom на практиці, наше завдання
зараз полягає в тому, щоб помістити слова у правильні
форми, які нам знадобляться, щоб поставити їх у
минуле просте іменне  kidnap estava
нудний рівень, ймовірно, немає офіційного першого
зразка, давайте подивимося на перше
речення, яке ви можете побачити, оскільки це
приклад нижньої діафрагми, яка молодша була
відома як попередній код року, гм, тож давайте
подивимося минулого року, коли я провів свою відпустку в
Ірландія Manoa Arakawa раніше Kaneko
ooh airline game map estava дами люблять
витрачати yacon суб'єктивний dooshka О
офіційні Manoa які є м'яким минулим простим
навіть hasta la fourmi провели Shamu поговорити
надіслати професіонала  phet Я просто люблю Осман
Мохаммед Атта - король молодший Еді, коли
О, Майя вибухає, немає офіційної віремії Маноло
Хатчісон в той момент, коли я провів
відпустку в Ірландії, речення номер два,
було б чудово, що нам потрібно сказати це в
минулому, і ми повинні використовувати  форма
дієслова to be в минулому проста форма
nom nom kidness Cassata повинна зберегти це
bellissimo normal cell below class no mo
no mo mo mo mo post avec des lava to be
oh man no leeches vomit imma show yet di
phenomenal hoses lava to  скажімо, це був
Лео Деніс, який був ягняти найін
національний Chatel NAS я пані я повинен лава it
yuck тема yuck piedmont itza odd nan
na dhanam of a pot kumihimo gt4 Medea
Slava was ми скажемо, що це було чудове
речення номер три я подорожую  навколо на
машині з двома друзями, і ми відвідуємо
багато цікавих місць
Oh JA Micajah Machaut Ponderosa wala
Moschino drew-sama if vid ми доставляємо
Hitachi Quebec nice, як ми кажемо, що
в минулому простому нам потрібно поставити
дієслова travel та відвідати його  до попередніх
зразків форм для цього нам просто потрібно
додати оголошення, тож ми скажемо, що я
подорожував автомобілем, і ми відвідали багато
цікавих місць номер чотири
вечорами ми зазвичай ходимо в паб чи
це відбувається зазвичай ні ми
описуємо  минулі події успіхи, які
запрошують мене Махавіра не передбачати завзятий
боулер сер Амано лама MIT проклав нах моя
мама GTG Слава іди жінка тільки для мене
Chima Buddha мати devatas akinci needy
чи лава йде нове ім'я Будда сказав
торкніться провінції Індія Slava Yakima Майамі
пост Овідія  Напевно, жодна офіційна прихована
установа, ймовірно, не може знати для моєї дорогої
Слави go oommen hola muchachas перший
зразок, який пішов, тому ми говоримо, що
вечорами ми зазвичай ходили в паб №
5, однієї ночі ми навіть вчимо деякі ірландські
танці, але без hava Chara, коли я з
virtually Airlines kitten see, тому нам
потрібно використовувати слово learn in past simple,
це дієслово є неправильним, нам потрібно буде
поставити його в past simple без
використання Edie,
тому ми дізналися, що це буде  правильна
форма цього дієслова в минулому
просто подивіться одного вечора ми навіть вивчили
кілька ірландських танців номер шість, нам дуже
пощастило з погодою, зараз Dora pasta
була ідеальною
mamama Scottish of Manolo mo sure stall
is not my mop estava nudious lava to be
o формальний Manolo висиджує
так гарячий транспортний засіб пронизує я був вище,
де був дивний рівень Ніни, де рівень національного майя,
де говорить, що маніакальний я на борту
патронів убуд емпіричні дані yak nom
Sam no Gina завтра мій переїзд кришталь
на офіційному вбранні, тому ми скажемо  що
нам дуже пощастило з погодою
номер 7, це не дуже багато, нам
потрібно використовувати заперечну форму дієслова
дощ у цьому випадку звичайно в минулому
простому мій авокадо що монолог
Діас lava rain
хто папуга Равана для мене давайте
відкрийте ще трохи сказав дозвіл
ідея повільніше зробив, що справедливість не може купити
мені машину часу gia Slava rain Takoma
Park Євген Майя Ох травматично в Китаї
Edie тому ми скажемо, що дощ не
було багато бомба атака em  необов'язково найбільший
Карачі Ніа чи не було багато дощу
номер вісім, але ми бачимо кілька прекрасних
веселок Alamo Bachelet відкладаємо
правильно добре, як ми сказати, що в
минулому простому нам знадобиться форма минулого простого
неправильного дієслова to see to
доповніть пробіл ми скажемо, що ми бачили
красиві веселки, давайте подивимося
на слайд і побачимо правильний варіант,
але ми побачили кілька красивих веселок
номер дев'ять,
де Бенджі, ваше останнє свято,
готовність попереднього перегляду, де ви можете
зібрати патату моєї матері, ми могли б
піч  або дешеве просте, щоб зробити
минуле просте запитання нам потрібен
допоміжний дієслово did Miami тому що до
дозволу ідеї Slava did your home a
pasta amo otra vez la putana Slava
you come to twist oppaya Slava де так звідки взяла Dolly
Mustafa mo pigment  ти
перетравний мій милий Слава провів Папа
Шадт іди переді мною Неста Омаха офіційний
пропуск простий
О J Омаха був паштет де ти
провів свою останню відпустку тому сьогодні ми
переглянули минуле  просто, і ми також
подорожували до Британського музею
Я сподіваюся, що зусилля були цікавими, я
сподіваюся, що ви пам'ятаєте
інформацію, яку ми відпрацювали, тому
команди Yahoo Abajo pav bhaji masala Stoke
nahoko
[Музика]
ви